un jeu pour les gourous qu'on a
découvert notamment avec la crise
sanitaire 1 c'est internet on est moins
soudé jaune mystique moins religieuse
comme on peut on pouvait la voir errer
110-80 que sur des phénomènes qui vont
concerner la santé ou l'alimentation et
la crise du coc vide à renforcer cette
nouvelle porte d'entrée dans les dérives
sectaires ou des goûts vont plutôt
parler de vaccination plutôt parler
d'alimentation plutôt parler de guérison
au lieu d'aller directement sur un
terrain qui sera un terrain religieux ou
mystique on retrouve par exemple dans
les dernières manifestations anti vaccin
contre le co lead certains éléments qui
se rattachent à des mouvements à
tendance sectaire qui historiquement
sont opposés à toute vaccination
[Musique]
le pass vaccinale est une forme déguisée
d'obligations vaccinale les mots du
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand au
lendemain de l'annoncé par le premier
ministre de la mise en place prochaine
de cette mesure le gouvernement change
donc de braquet et de quoi renforcer la
colère des protestataires qui dénoncent
depuis des semaines des mesures qu'ils
jugent liberticide
ils sont à nouveau descendus dans la rue
ce samedi
[Musique]
les pays-bas se confirme dès demain et
pour les fêtes de noël face à la
propagation du variant omicron les
restrictions se multiplient dans lieu
les 27 qui appelle à une coordination
mais dans les faits chaque état membre
rivalité mesures pour tenter d'endiguer
la vague épidémique
six pays dont l'italie et la grèce sont
ainsi mises en place des conditions
spécifiques pour entrer sur leur
territoire
[Musique]
cet effectif la russie se retire du
traité ciel ouvert annoncé il ya
plusieurs mois en réaction à la sortie
des états unis la décision est entrée en
vigueur sauf un et signé par le pays en
92 et ratifiée en 2001 le texte autorise
des vols de surveillance militaires non
armés au dessus des pays membres
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france le gouvernement
assume très clairement de faire pression
sur les non vaccinés la décision a été
annoncée hier par jean castex le pass
sanitaire va se transformer en passe
vaccinale seule la vaccination sera
valable et non plus un simple test
négatif
interrogé aujourd'hui par le média brut
le ministre de la santé a déclaré que le
pass vaccinale est une forme déguisée
d'obligations vaccinale mais c'est plus
efficace qu'une obligation vaccinale fin
de citation un projet de loi sera soumis
au parlement début janvier les
restaurants cafés cinémas lieux de
loisirs ne seront donc bientôt plus
accessible qu'aux personnes vaccinées
convaincra plutôt que contraindre
c'était pourtant le credo des manuels
macron le récit de thé au combat
affirmer quelque chose avant de se
contredire dans les grandes largeurs
quelques semaines plus tard c'est
l'opération à laquelle le gouvernement
et le président de la république se
livrent depuis plusieurs mois concernant
l'obligation vaccinale en novembre 2020
déjà le sujet est sur la table alors que
la france commence à peine à recevoir
les doses de sérum je ne rendrai pas la
vaccination obligatoire un discours que
le chef de l'état maintiendra alors que
la troisième vague de covile 19 déferle
sur la france mon souhait c'est plutôt
de ne pas le rendre obligatoire mais
c'est de convaincre tout le monde que
c'est par le vaccin que nous pourrons
nous en sortir finalement c'est la
propagation du variant delta et une
campagne de vaccination ralenti qui
pousse le locataire de l'elysée à se
contredire une première fois en juillet
emmanuel macron annonce une vaccination
obligatoire pour les soignants avant la
fin de l'année dans un premier temps
pour les personnels soignants et non
soignants des hôpitaux des cliniques des
maisons de retraite des établissements
pour personnes en situation de handicap
pour tous les professionnels aux
bénévoles qui travaillent au contact des
personnes âgées ou fragiles y compris à
domicile
la vaccination sera rendue obligatoire
sans attendre
une volte-face qui en présager une autre
ce vendredi après avoir reçu le feu vert
du chef de l'état le premier ministre a
affirmé sa volonté de transformer le
pass and i ter en passe vaccinale une
obligation vaccinale déguisés qui
pourrait bientôt présager d'une
vaccination obligatoire en bonne et due
forme pour l'ensemble de la population
un an jour pour jour après avoir annoncé
s'il refusait fermement à de multiples
reprises emmanuel macron pourrait se
dédire une nouvelle fois et la décision
n'a pas manqué de faire réagir notamment
le leader du mouvement des patriotes qui
chaque samedi depuis plusieurs semaines
un appel à la mobilisation pour dénoncer
des mesures qu'ils jugent liberticide
on écoute florian philippot
c'est une nouvelle déclaration de guerre
aux français voilà il nous a fait une
déclaration de guerre
passeport vaccinale ses obligations
vaccinales déguisés derrière véran s'en
cachent même plus donc c'est absurde du
point de vue de la science puisque le
vaccin n'empêche pas la transmission on
voit bien à l'explosion des cas alors
qu'on a le passeport sanitaires depuis
quatre mois tout ça est d'elliant point
de vue scientifique c'est délirant et du
point de vue des principes c'est un
effondrement c'est que là on assume on
se cache plus y'a des moins que rien
sont les 6 millions non vaccinés puis
tous ceux qui sont aujourd'hui max ils
aiment et qu'ils seront considérés
administrativement bientôt comme non
vaccinés parce que ils vont courir après
les doses avec un moment il y en a qui
vont lâcher c'est tous les quatre mois
quelles nouvelles doses donc tout ça et
voilà c'est sombre c'est inhumain un
colère aussi des et gilet jaune ils sont
aussi à nouveau descendus dans la rue
pour dénoncer les mesures sanitaires du
gouvernement et demander aussi plus de
justice sociale notre reporter david
khalifa a suivi le cortège parisien
plusieurs centaines de gilet jaune eux
rassemblés dans la rue cet après midi à
paris en partant de la place de la
bourse pour atteindre l'hôpital
saint-antoine en passant par la place de
la bastille où je me trouve actuellement
l'objectif dénoncer les agissements du
gouvernement concernant cette crise
sanitaire en référence notamment aux
dernières déclarations de jean castex
hier soir sur la transformation du
passani terre en passe vaccinale à
plusieurs reprises le cortège s'est
arrêté dans la rue parisienne pour
sensibiliser les passants sur les
dangers de l'obligation vaccinale pour
eux c'est une nous l atteinte aux
libertés individuelles tout comme le
pass sanitaire considérée comme
liberticide
je vous propose d'écouter quelques mains
des manifestants là on constate depuis
hier et les interventions de jean castex
vraiment une accélération de la de
l'oppression vaccinale est donc donc là
même les gens qui ont eu le coc vide et
qui sont immunisés au même les gens qui
font des tests ne pourront plus circuler
librement puisque ça ne va plus être un
pass sanitaire mais abbas vaccinale donc
là on est vraiment dans une restriction
des libertés jamais vu donc donc c'est
un scandale et donc j'appelle j'appelle
les gens à prendre conscience de la
gravité de ce qui se passe et et à
bouger réagir quoi parce que là on est
vraiment dans quelque chose d'inédit il
n'y a pas de colère particulier en tout
cas pas pas plus qu'on en avait
précédemment puisque c'est la
confirmation de ce qu'on pensait depuis
toujours politique totalitaire pas ce
qui n'a rien de sanitaires mais qui est
un pass totalitaire et maintenant
vaccinale les légendes donc le mot
résistance à la bouche mais il ne faut
pas le galvauder pour j'appelle tous les
gilets déjà et tous mes compatriotes
tous tous mes congénères même au pad au
delà même de mes compatriotes à résister
à empêcher ce cette entreprise
criminelle les autres revendications des
gilets jaunes s'inscrivent dans la
continuité depuis maintenant plus de
trois ans notamment le riz que le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne mais
elle est également la destitution de
tous les hommes politiques qui
trahissent le peuple selon leurs mots
l'objectif pour les ailes gilet jaune
c'est que le mouvement s'inscrivent dans
la durée afin de pouvoir peser dans la
balance lors des prochaines élections
présidentielles le cortège en tout cas
cet après midi n'a connu aucun incident
encadrés par un dispositif de sécurité
plutôt minime par rapport aux autres
rassemblements un nouveau samedi de
mobilisation donc l'expression des trois
grandes crises du moment selon le
sociologue michel fize éditorialistes
arte france
je crois qu'il faut rappeler que nous
avons dans la rue l'expression des trois
grandes crises du moment la crise
économique et
sociale avec le gilet jaune la crise
sanitaire avec les personnes nanties
passe et la crise politique tel que peut
l'exprimer notamment florian philippot
ono nom des patriotes rien de nouveau il
ya trois ans nous aurions pu le faire le
même constat aujourd'hui évidemment on
nous ressort des moyennes un pouvoir
d'achat qui
auraient reculé ou reculerait un petit
peu en réalité
la ménagère quand elle fait les courses
elle s'aperçoit que il ya des produits
qui sont aujourd'hui inaccessibles
d'autres qui ont fait des bonds
spectaculaires ont parlé du papier
toilette on parlait des pâtes on
pourrait citer beaucoup d'autres
beaucoup d'autres exemples donc
incontestablement il ya un élargissement
des inégalités sociales je rappelle au
passage que les 10% des français les
plus pauvres gagne environ 700 euros par
mois tandis que les 10% les plus riches
gagnent 5000 euros environ net et après
impôts ouais on voit là les l'étendue
détendu des dégâts donc il est évident
que l'effritement du pouvoir d'achat n'a
pas la même signification c'est long
quand on est en haut ou en bas
naturellement
à part tout en europe les restrictions
se multiplient chez aux pays-bas les
autorités sert considérablement la vie
le premier ministre annonce annonce ce
soir un confinement pendant les fêtes de
noël il entre en vigueur dès demain des
restrictions qui immobilise contre l
illustration au royaume-uni alors qu
mikron séville très fortement dans le
pays le premier ministre boris johnson
annoncé de nouvelles mesures à la
fraîche des fêtes de fin d'année si le
télétravail fait son retour la mise en
place d'un pass sanitaires pour entrer
dans les lieux accueillant un public
important est une première de quoi faire
descendre dans les rues de londres des
milliers de protestataires cet après
midi le maire de la ville se dit de son
côté inquiet pour l'économie du pays
les impacts des deux dernières semaines
ont été dévastateurs les théâtres les
bars les restaurants les concerts ont vu
leur réservation annulée et leur
fréquentation a chuté par rapport aux
réservations annulées elle la
fréquentation du west inde a énormément
baissé donc le commerce de détail va
souffrir et c'est pourquoi nous faisons
appel aux gouvernements et tous hier que
le gouvernement fournisse un ensemble de
mesures financières des subventions une
réduction de 100 % des taux d'imposition
des entreprises plus de nouvelles
concernant les congés si le gouvernement
ne le fait pas de très nombreuses
entreprises vont faire faillite et des
dizaines de milliers de personnes vont
perdre leur emploi
mais en ligne de mire des autorités est
partout dans lieu le variant omicron il
se propage à vitesse grand v et c'est
une nouvelle fois en ordre dispersé les
vingt-sept réagissent certains pays
n'hésitent pas à réinstaurer des
conditions d'entrée sur leur territoire
y compris aux états membres les
explications d'yves olivier b
le variant omicron serait-il en train de
mettre au jour les fragilités de la
défense sanitaire européenne la question
n'est pas anodine au vu des dernières
décisions prises par plusieurs pays à
l'instar de l'italie qui impose depuis
jeudi et jusqu'au 31 janvier un test
négatif de dépistage du coc vide 19 à
tous les voyageurs de plus de 6 ans
quand bien même ceux-ci présenterait un
schéma vaccinal complet une exception
est faite cependant aux personnes
transitant dans le pays durant moins de
36 heures ou qui resteraient avec un
motif impérieux pour moins de 120 heures
en belgique on applique peu ou prou des
règles similaires mais uniquement aux
personnes non vaccinées obligation pour
les voyageurs de présenter un test pcr
de moins de 72 heures s'il arrive de
zone rouge c'est à dire là où le virus
circule activement il leur sera ensuite
demandé à un nouveau test au septième
jour de leur séjour pour quitter
prématurément la quarantaine de dix
jours qui leur est imposé à noter que
selon le classement des autorités belges
il peut y avoir des zones rouges et des
zones orange au sein d'un même pays en
france par exemple la guadeloupe saint
barthélémy ou encore la nouvelle
calédonie sont en orange alors que la
martinique la guyane et l'essentiel des
régions métropolitaines sont en rouge
plus souple l'espagne et l'allemagne
reste sur l'idée de la preuve de
vaccination de 14 jours minimum ou de
guérison des moins de six mois du coc
vide peut également être présenté un
test pcr de moins de 72 heures ou
antigénique de moins de deux jours à
noter que pour toutes ces destinations à
l'exception de l'allemagne un formulaire
de traçabilité à remplir est exigée au
moment de l'entrée sur leur sol enfin
désormais hors de l'union européenne la
grande-bretagne l'autorisent désormais
l'accès à son territoire que pour motif
impérieux en plus de l'obligation de
présenter un test pcr de 48 heures il
faut apporter la preuve d'achat d'un
autre test a effectué deux jours après
l'arrivée au royaume uni les personnes
non vaccinées auront deux tests à
acheter et à faire au 2e et 8e jours du
séjour enfin elles auront un isolement
de dix jours à respecter à domicile ou
dans un hôtel
s est officiellement en raison de la
crise sanitaire en france qu emmanuel
macron annulé sa visite au mali le chef
de l'état devait rencontrer son
homologue malien et se rendre aux côtés
des troupes françaises présentes sur
place
un voyage jugé à haut risque dont les
relations sont électriques entre paris
et bamako le récit de robes actuelle
après l'annulation de la visite des
manuels macron paris peine à dissimuler
ses dissensions avec bamako principal
point de tension entre les deux pays le
non respect du calendrier de transition
démocratique presque sept mois après le
putsch les colonels malien tarder à
organiser les élections prévues en
février prochain pour aborder ce sujet
emmanuel macron souhaité élargir sa
première rencontre avec assise meego ita
ou présidents africains de la cedeao et
du g5 sahel une configuration rapidement
écartée par l'homme fort du pouvoir
militaire autres dissensions la
possibilité d'une collaboration entre la
junte et le groupe nerfs paris souhaite
à tout prix éviter que le gouvernement
malien fasse appel aux mercenaires il ne
peut pas y avoir cohabitation le groupe
wagner n'a quand même pas une très
grande
une réputation très positive ne
n'oublions pas quand même il est accusé
d'un certain nombre de méfaits dans
d'autres pays dont la centrafrique et
donc on peut pas se retrouver dans un
contexte comme le mali avec une force
privé de mercenaires avec une force
régaliennes comme celle de la france qui
vient aider le mali il faut faire un
choix sans aucun doute des ressentiments
qui existent également dans le camp
malien depuis plusieurs mois les
représentants du pouvoir multiplie les
attaques contre la france on septembre
quelques semaines après l'annoncé d'un
plan de réorganisation de la force
barkan
le premier ministre cheikh guèye kokalla
maïga dénoncé un abandon à la tribune
des nations unies mardi dernier dans un
entretien diffusé sur la bbc abdoulaye
diop chef de la diplomatie a affirmé que
les deux pays entretenaient actuellement
des relations difficiles un sentiment
partagé par une partie de la population
malienne de plus en plus critique à
l'égard de l'action française dans leur
pays en huit ans de présence au mali
varin française n'a rien foutu il faut
le dire
je dirais une des séries des parts pour
la nation malienne une des scènes
complètement perdus comme ça
c'est un bilan catastrophique surnom
quand la france dit qu'ils gagnent les
balles la base peut aller de l'autre
côté moi je vois que ce sont des choses
pour pouvoir et conquérir le pouvoir
malien c'est archi faux assis ne va pas
se laisser faire et le peuple malien si
c'est pas un crime c'est le peuple
malien va pas se laisser faire sur le
terrain la réorganisation de la force
barkan se poursuit en début de semaine
l'armée française a rétrocédé le camp de
tombouctou à l'armée malienne après
quasiment neuf ans de présence paris
prévoit une réduction des effectifs au
sahel de 5000 hommes à moins de 3000
d'ici à 2023 et depuis bamako notre
grand reporter régis le sommier y
revient sur ses relations tendues entre
la france et le mali en écoute tant
l'homme de la rue que dans les
administrations
il y à ce sentiment ce sentiment
d'abandon qui avait été comment
illustrer par la spectaculaire
déclarations du premier ministre cheikh
guèye maïga dans la tribune des nations
unies
qui disait que la france abandonne le
mali en plein vol ça c'est quelque chose
qui revient de façon récurrente
la france vous l'avez souligné aussi a
quitté la base de tombouctou c'est un
symbole c'était là où françois hollande
avait fait en 2013 son fameux discours
de victoire contre les colonnes
djihadistes ap il faut rappeler que
depuis la force serval à l'époque s'est
transformé en barres cannes elle a passé
sept ans au mali il ya eu énormément de
de commandes de coopération entre les
maliens et les français est aujourd'hui
ce retrait du nord est perçu ici comme
un moment d'incertitude à un moment
presque de peur en abandonnant ou
quittant le nord la force barca les
biens d'une certaines façon laisse libre
cours à céder à ces terroristes puisque
une certain nombre de ces groupes
pratiquent le comment l'enlèvement il
faut pas l'oublier ce sont des gens qui
utilisent les populations à des fins
pour l'heure pour leurs combattants pour
doki kadri toutes ces zones
ce 18 décembre marque la journée
internationale des migrants langue
l'occasion pour plusieurs collectifs
syndicats et associations d'appeler un
rassemblement national pour se souvenir
des drames migratoires et s'interroger
sur la politique en la matière
qu'applique l'union européenne la
manifestation se voulait aussi
l'occasion de dénoncer toutes les formes
de racisme dont sont victimes les
étrangers compte rendu notre reporter
n'a déjà des attaques
une manifestation qui a réuni plus d'un
millier de personnes des migrants bien
sûr mais également et des militants
associatifs ou encore à des
représentants syndicaux l'objectif de ce
rassemblement aujourd'hui c'était de
dire non au racisme et puis de demander
à plus de dignité pour aider sans
papiers qui réclament la régularisation
pour tous je vous proposais à ce sujet
d'écouter quelques manifestants que l'on
a pu interroger tout à l'heure et la
france est elle accueille une infime
partie des flux migratoires a aussi un
faut arrêter de se faire passer pour un
pays submergé
c'est du pipeau tout ça c'est de la
propagande ne sont pas des délinquants
pendant qu'on entend dans les médias
c'est comme si on nous prend pour des
délinquants nous sommes là si on a fait
notre façon on n'a pas le choix sinon
nous on voudrait prendre l'avion venir
en france on en parle passée par là mais
terne ou d'un passé par
deux voire dangereux on n'a pas la
solution par la médiation n'a pas le
choix on aimerait rester ce nom dans la
dignité
l'air du temps est mauvais il est même
carrément pourri errance à l'égard des
étrangers et que je fais partie des gens
qui se battent pour le droit toute
personne vivre ici dans des conditions
décentes je crois que les étrangers sont
très en danger en ce moment en france et
notre société tout entière est très en
danger leur régularisation de tous les
travailleurs sans papiers en france ans
est l'une des revendications majeures
des manifestants présents ici ils
veulent que la cause des migrants soit
l'un des thèmes majeurs qu'il le pèse
sur la campagne électorale et pour ça
ils ont d'ores et déjà prévu d'autres
rassemblements dans les semaines et dans
l'émoi une
manifestation à barcelone en espagne ils
étaient des dizaines de milliers dans
les rues de la capitale de la catalogne
pour réclamer l' usage exclusif du
catalan dont les écoles une
manifestation en réponse à la décision
prise par le tribunal suprême fin
novembre imposer un quota minimum de 25%
d'espagnol dans les écoles catalanes ces
écoles fonctionnent pourtant
exclusivement avec le catalan depuis
près de 40 ans
c'est
par là
je suis père de deux petites filles qui
vont à l'école et je suis venue
manifester pour revendiquer une école en
catalogne qui reste en catalan qui est
la langue de notre pays ce doit être la
langue véhiculaire pour les usages
publics après la maison chacun parle
bien sûr la langue qu'il veut mais dans
l' usage social le catalan devrait être
la langue de communication car
je suis enseignant et j'ai participé à
la mise en place de l'immersion et je
peux assurer que c'est un modèle de
réussite qui a contribué à la cohésion
sociale et il est prouvé que
l'apprentissage des deux langues se fait
de la même manière et donc il n'y a
aucune raison de remettre en question ce
modèle est au parc national acadia belle
claque à ce moment l'important je pense
que c'est très important de connaître
plusieurs langues et pas seulement deux
mais ce serait intéressant aussi d'avoir
plus d'anglais à l'école moi par exemple
j'ai toujours étudiées en catalan et je
sais m'exprimer parfaitement en espagnol
il faut trouver un moyen pour que la
langue minoritaire soit davantage
protégés a secoué dimanche
c'est désormais acté la russie quitte le
traité ciel ouvert ce samedi son retrait
avait été validé par la douma francs mai
dernier en réaction aux retraites des
états unis en novembre 2020 ce traité
autorise des vols de surveillance
militaires non armés au dessus des pays
membres la correspondance à moscou de
veyra goffman
en mauve ou pillées de la sécurité
internationale est tombé après le départ
des etats unis elle la russie à son tour
quitte le traité si est le vert et comme
d'habitude lorsque en accord s'effondre
les responsables se trouve du côté de
moscou je pense que nous avons de très
bonnes relations avec la russie mais la
russie n'a pas adhéré au traité ciel
ouvert donc en attendant le moment où il
y adhèrent nous nous en retirons mais il
est fort probable qu ont conclu un
nouvel accord ou qu'on fasse quelque
chose pour rétablir cet accord là qu'on
le sait très bien maintenant cela n'a
pas eu lieu signé en 1992 le traité ciel
vert est devenu l'une des mesures phares
en matière de transparence et de
confiance dans le domaine des activités
militaires et du contrôle des armements
après la fin de la guerre froide les 34
au pays adhérents ont traité en obtenu
le droit de survoler leur territoire
respectif
quelques décennies auparavant le
président américain eisenhower avait
proposé à leurs et cesse de négocier une
surveillance aérienne mutuelle afin
d'éviter une frappe conquiert soudaine
jeté pendant près de 30 ans le traité
ciel ouvert à aider toutes les parties à
mieux comprendre les intentions
militaires des autres et à cet égard le
retrait des etats-unis du traité ciel
ouvert unilatérale et en invoquant des
prétextes imaginaire a gravement
perturbé l'équilibré des intérêts et a
mis notre pays dans une position inégale
en termes de transparence militaire et
dans ces circonstances la participation
de moscou au traité a complètement perdu
son sens
ironie du sort cette décision de donald
trump de quitter le traité a été
critiquée par le président actuel joe
biden au lieu de détruire des traités
qui renforce notre sécurité et celle de
nos alliés le président trump devrait
prendre des mesures de bon sens pour
assurer la sécurité des amis il devrait
rester dans le traité ciel ouvert et
travailler avec les alliés pour
affronter et résoudre les problèmes liés
aux engagements de la russie du
président joe biden a cependant suivi la
ligne de donald trump très cohérent les
états unis regrettent que le traité ciel
ouvert et été sapée par des infractions
venant de la russie en conclusion de
leur examen du traité les états unis
n'ont donc pas l'intention de chercher à
le rejoindre étant donné que la russie
n'a pris aucune mesure pour revenir au
respect de ces dispositions
la russie de son côté affirme qu'elle a
fait tout son possible pour maintenir le
traité en vie jusqu'au bout la
fédération de russie entrepris toutes
sortes d'efforts pour sauvegarder le
traité on a fait preuve de patience
donnant à l'administration américaine la
possibilité de décider de revenir au
sein du traité ciel ouvert ainsi le 24
mai un aide mémoire de plusieurs pages
contenant une analyse des revendications
mutuelle portant sur le traité a été
envoyée à la partie américaine
or le 27 mai le département d'état
américain a informé le ministère russe
des affaires étrangères que washington
avait décidé de ne pas revenir aux
traités avec le retrait de là aussi est
des états unis du traité ciel vert et
donc la fin de facto de cet accord
l'avenir de la stabilité internationale
semble plus vulnérable que jamais
à l'ère des réseaux sociaux les technos
multiplient facebook vient d'admettre
que son système de facto king n'était
pas neutre l'aveu intervient à la suite
d'une plainte déposée par un journaliste
aveu qui pose de nombreuses questions
toutes les précisions de notre
correspondant à washington tom abonnés à
entendre facebook ou plutôt devrais-je
dire mais tape le fact checking est plus
que jamais nécessaire dans un monde
pollué par les fake news et la
désinformation en ligne c'est donc en
vertu de ces combats que l'entreprise a
multiplié ces dernières années les
avertissements à poser sur certaines
pages et certaines publications des
annotations imposé par facebook lorsque
la plateforme juge qu'un contenu est
faux un journaliste américain a tenté de
contester cette mesure furieux que la
plateforme qualifie une de ses vidéos de
partiellement fausses dans cette vidéo
il affirmé que la principale cause des
incendies qui ont détruit des forêts
californienne est fait en réalité la
mauvaise gestion forestière du
gouvernement américain en admettant que
le changement climatique il y avait
toutefois contribuer une procédure a
donc été lancée en justice journaliste
accuse facebook de diffamation car elle
remet en cause la mention apposer par la
plateforme sur sa publication et voici
la réponse de l'entreprise
les mentions elle même ne sont ni fausse
ni diffamatoires au contraire elle
constitue de l'opinion protéger une
opinion protéger donc facebook admet que
le fact checking mais pas neutre en
reconnaissant cela la plateforme se tire
une balle dans le pied car voici ce que
la même entreprise disait il ya quelques
mois au sujet des articles d'opinion si
le contenu est présenté comme une
opinion mais qu'il repose sur des
informations fausses sous jacentes il
est éligible à la vérification des
informations
même s'il s'agit d'une tribune libre ou
d'un éditorial pourquoi parce que la
publication de contenus relevant de
l'opinion ne donne pas l'autorisation de
diffuser des fausses informations d'où
ces questions qui décide qu'une opinion
et protégés ou non en somme qui
factcheck les facs checkers on en vient
donc à la conclusion que ceux censés
détenir la vérité ne sont évidemment pas
100% objectif facebook décident
simplement quelle opinion sont protégés
ou non et se base évidemment sur des
considérations idéologiques
pour ne rien vous cacher on le savait
déjà il suffit de voir quels médias sont
étiquetés d'une mention concernant leur
financement et ceux qui ne le sont pas
mais en politisant ces plateformes en
ligne ne risque-t-on pas de se priver de
certains utilisateurs et par conséquent
de certaines opinions le fait que
l'ancien président américain donald
trump est décidé de lancer son propre
réseau social pour dit-il contrer la
pensée unique des géants du numérique on
est l'ultime illustration
c'est la fin de cette édition se
retrouve à 21h pour un nouveau journal à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
ton
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]